It is so chaotic and ridiculous that I am confident that it will not last. And by not last, I don't mean that like Twitter will be destroyed. I believe Twitter is more resilient than Elon. I believe that Twitter will outlast and will eventually be fine. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 109 recorded on December 22nd 2022. My name is Connor and today with my co host Bryce we do our third holiday special where we talk about whatever we want a plethora of topics including Twitter, Elon Musk, Christmas trees, travel, and so much more. Folks, for the first time in over a month and a half, let's actually take a look at the exact dates. We recorded on, today is one day before this goes out.
情况非常混乱且荒谬，我坚信这种情况不会持续太久。我说的“不会持续”并不是指推特会彻底毁灭。我相信推特比埃隆更有韧性。我相信推特会挺过去，最终会没事的。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客第 109 期，录制于 2022 年 12 月 22 日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯带来了我们的第三期节日特辑，我们想聊什么就聊什么，话题包罗万象，包括推特、埃隆·马斯克、圣诞树、旅行等等。各位，在一个半多月以来（让我们看看具体的日期），我们上次录音是今天的前一天。
Are those new headphones i have that that model uh no these i've been using for months now so you're okay we it doesn't even actually say so yeah we recorded we recorded on november 2nd with Jane. Yeah. And the last time we recorded without a guest together was October 27th. So it's almost been two months. It's almost been two months since we've had a mano a mano ADSP recording. I've been looking forward to this because I actually haven't talked to you. And like you were gone to Kona and then to Japan and then to Amsterdam. And since you've been back I've I was away for a bit anyways how's it going first of all happy holidays I think I think we agreed last year we're allowed to say Merry Christmas
那是新耳机吗？我有的那个型号，呃，没有，这个我已经用了好几个月了，所以没关系，其实上面甚至都没写。所以，是的，我们是 11 月 2 日跟简一起录的。对。而我们上次没有嘉宾、只有我们俩一起录音是在 10 月 27 日。所以差不多有两个月了。我们已经差不多两个月没有进行面对面的 ADSP 录音了。我一直很期待这个，因为我实际上一直没跟你聊过。就像你去了科纳，然后去日本，然后去阿姆斯特丹。你回来之后，反正我也离开了一会儿，最近怎么样？首先，祝大家节日快乐。我想，我想我们去年一致同意我们可以说“圣诞快乐”
because it's our podcast and we can do what we want but did we well we did I have a Christmas tree wait one second oh yeah so Merry Christmas Hanukkah, Happy Holidays to whatever non-religion or religion or religious thing. Can you see the Christmas tree back there? I can, yes. And I also see a, what is that called? A stocking? A little Santa's boot stocking? I have successfully not set the apartment on fire.
因为这是我们的播客，我们想做什么就做什么，但我们真的说过吗？嗯，我们说过。我有一棵圣诞树，等等，哦，对，所以祝大家圣诞快乐、光明节快乐、节日快乐，不管是什么非宗教、宗教还是与宗教相关的事。你能看到后面的圣诞树吗？我能，是的。我还看到一个，那个叫什么？长筒袜？一个小圣诞老人靴长筒袜？我成功地没有把公寓烧毁。
Is it a real tree? Yeah. It's a real tree. is that allowed in your apartment are you breaking rules here and hopefully none of the uh well the doorman the doorman helped me bring it up so i'm pretty sure that it's probably it's okay damn why so uh you know just try and try trying out different holidays what's going on brace well i'm jewish but the girlfriend is not jewish so i see i see you've compromised yeah although i've you've told me well no i got i got it i got it as a surprise but she's not like you know super into christmas but she never really had like christmas tree growing up so i was like all right well we got a good christmas tree gotta get a christmas tree i do not have a Christmas tree. I've got plants, but no Christmas tree because it's more work than it's worth.
那是真的树吗？对。是真的树。你公寓里允许放这个吗？你是在违反规定吗？希望没有……嗯，门卫，门卫帮我把它搬上来的，所以我很确定这大概，应该是没问题的。天哪，为什么……呃，你知道的，就是尝试不同的节日。布莱斯，最近怎么样？嗯，我是犹太人，但我女朋友不是犹太人，所以我懂，我懂。你折中了一下。是的，不过你告诉我……不，我买的，我把它当作一个惊喜，但她其实并没有那么……你知道的，特别喜欢圣诞节，而且她从小到大也从来没有过过圣诞树，所以我想，好吧，既然我们得有一棵好圣诞树，那就得弄一棵圣诞树。我没有圣诞树。我有植物，但没有圣诞树，因为这比它带来的价值要麻烦得多。
Yeah, it does seem to be like a lot of work. And, you know, I – so, okay. All right. Also, too, let's just pause here. Folks, this is our third holiday special episode. If you're new to the podcast and didn't go watch the entire backlog, which, I mean, come on, what are you doing? You're probably on holiday right now. Head back to episode zero and work your way through it. We talk about whatever we want to today. So it's going to probably be 30 minutes, 60 minute episode. Last year, I think we committed to going on a trip to Sloveniavenia our number one our number one country and uh we called that episode uh holiday special ljubljana which is the capital of slovenia here we come and uh the first year who knows what we talked about two years ago but anyways back to you bryce so for folks thinking this isn't
对，这确实看起来很麻烦。而且，你知道，我——所以，好吧。好吧，另外，我们也在这里暂停一下。各位，这是我们的第三期节日特辑节目。如果你是这个播客的新听众，还没有去听完整的前期节目（我的意思是，拜托，你在干什么呢？你现在可能正在度假）。回到第 0 集，从头开始听吧。我们今天要随心所欲地聊任何想聊的话题。所以这大概会是一个 30 分钟到 60 分钟的节目。去年，我想我们承诺过要去斯洛文尼亚旅行，这是我们的头号国家，我们把那一期节目叫做“节日特辑：卢布尔雅那，斯洛文尼亚的首都，我们来啦”，而第一年，谁知道两年前我们聊了什么呢。不过无论如何，回到你身上，布莱斯，所以对于那些觉得这并不是
technical in nature you know that's this is what i wanted to surprise the girlfriend with the christmas tree um and uh so i did all the preparations she was in uh portland for work and so i i did all the preparations that week um but i then she came back in the weekend and so i had everything like prepared i had all the gifts wrapped and like hidden in various places around the apartment and that part was actually easy because she's short she's like five feet tall and so i just put everything, not even high. I didn't even put things at like a high height. I just put things at like a regular height for me.
充满技术性质的人来说，你知道，这就是我想给女朋友一个惊喜的圣诞树，呃，所以我在她去波特兰出差的那周做了所有的准备工作，但然后她在周末回来了，所以我把一切都准备好了，我把所有的礼物都包好，藏在公寓里的各个地方。这部分其实很容易，因为她个子很矮，大概五英尺高，所以我把所有的东西都放得很低，甚至没有放得很高。我甚至没有把东西放在很高的位置。我只是把东西放在对她来说是个正常的高度。
And I'm like, I didn't even have to worry about her looking up because she just like her awareness of the world ends at like six feet. And she's not going to look up taller than that. So I just hit all of the gifts um and uh i i i you know i asked people on twitter for advice about uh you know how how to buy a tree and pretty much all of my uh respected friends and colleagues on twitter told me you should buy an artificial tree um because know, it's a lot less hassle, it's less expensive. But she had said she likes the smell of pine. So I ignored
而且我想，我甚至都不用担心她会抬头看，因为她对这个世界的认知在六英尺左右就结束了，她是不会抬头看比这更高的地方的。所以我把所有的礼物都藏好了，呃，我，你知道的，我在推特上向大家征求关于怎么买树的建议，几乎所有我在推特上尊敬的朋友和同事都告诉我，你应该买一棵人造树，因为你知道，这样麻烦少得多，也便宜得多。但她说她喜欢松树的香味。所以我忽略了
everybody's very timely and wise advice and bought a tree. But I determined that I needed to buy a tree on Sunday, and she had tennis at 2 on Sunday. And then she was going to come back at around 4.30, and then she had a facial at 5.30. We're getting a whole – giving people a lot of information to stalk your girlfriend here. But so what I felt needed to happen was that after she got back from the facial, that's when the tree needed to be set up. And I was going to cook dinner that night. So I would have between like 5.40 and 7 to set up the tree and to sort of set everything up. And so my plan was, okay, when she's playing tennis, I'll go and buy the tree and I'll get the doorman to hide it somewhere in the building.
大家非常及时和明智的建议，买了一棵真树。但我决定在周日买一棵树，而她周日两点有网球课。然后她大概四点半回来，接着她五点半要做个面部护理。我们给听众提供了一大堆可以去跟踪你女朋友的信息。但我觉得应该发生的是，在她做完面部护理回来后，那就是需要布置圣诞树的时候。而且那天晚上我要做晚饭。所以我将有大约 5点 40 到 7 点之间的时间来搭建圣诞树并把所有东西都布置好。所以我的计划是，好吧，当她在打网球的时候，我去买树，并让门卫把它藏在楼里的某个地方。
And then I'll start the food prep for dinner. And then when she's at the face show i'll do the actual setup and i made a mistake and the mistake was that like a day or two before uh the event i i was just gonna make like steak because she just loves steak like steak and steamed vegetables and mashed potatoes like that that is like her ideal meal and like like i'm not saying that she likes bland food she just she likes very simple food you know she likes she likes steak is not bland she likes simple food like done well she like she doesn't want things that are like over seasoned um but so that meal was going to be simple, but then like a day or two before,
然后我开始准备晚饭的食材。接着当她在做面部护理的时候，我来进行实际的布置。结果我犯了个错误，这个错误就是，在活动发生前的一两天，我本来只是打算做牛排，因为她太喜欢牛排了——就像牛排配蒸蔬菜和土豆泥，那简直是她理想中的大餐。我并不是说她喜欢清淡的食物，她只是喜欢非常简单的食物，你知道的，她喜欢……牛排可不算清淡，她喜欢烹饪得恰到好处的简单食物。她不喜欢调味过重的食物。所以那顿饭本来很简单，但就在前一两天，
my favorite YouTube chef and baker, I saw a new video from him on this potato soup, and I'm like, that looks really good. I'm going to make that instead. So I printed out the recipe, I did all the meal prep, but it's a soup. And soups, you know, tend to take a bit of time. They have to simmer and they tend to need a bit of attention. In particular, this one, it needed, there were like, there were two steps where I needed to do something for 10 minutes. And then there was one step where I needed it to like simmer for 40 minutes. So there were like 30 minutes of like active cook time and like where i needed to be at the stove during this recipe and i only realized this after i had purchased the tree and after she'd come back uh and and was in the apartment before she
我最喜欢的 YouTube 厨师兼烘焙师发布了关于这款土豆汤的新视频，我想，看起来真不错。我打算改做这个。所以我打印了食谱，做好了所有的食材准备，但这是一道汤。你知道，汤通常需要花点时间。它们需要慢炖，而且往往需要一些关注。特别是这个，它需要……有两个步骤我需要做 10 分钟的事情。然后还有一个步骤需要它慢炖 40 分钟。所以大概有 30 分钟的实际烹饪时间，在这个食谱制作过程中我必须待在炉灶旁。而我直到买完树、她回来之后、在她出门做面部护理之前，才意识到这一点。
left for the facial and so then i realized oh crap in addition to having just about an hour to uh set up and and decorate this tree and set up all the presents um I'm also gonna have to cook dinner and like be at the stove at the same time so oh and and I had you know the dog in the apartment who was very confused and scared by the Christmas tree. And I also had to get a bow on the dog, which was no easy feat. So about five minutes before she comes back into the apartment, things are like a complete chaos. I'm like, oh, I'm not ready. But then everything sort of came together but i got christmas tree lights um like the ones you plug into the wall but then i realized um
然后我才意识到，糟糕，除了只有一个小时左右的时间来搭建、装饰这棵树并摆好所有的礼物之外，我还得做晚饭，并且同时得守在炉灶旁。哦，而且公寓里还有那只对圣诞树感到非常困惑和害怕的狗。我还得给狗系上一个蝴蝶结，这可绝非易事。所以在她回到公寓前的五分钟左右，事情简直是一团糟。我想，天哪，我还没准备好。但随后一切总算凑合着完成了。不过我买的圣诞树灯是那种插在墙上的，但我意识到
like they're a different kind well no what yes there is there there are battery operated ones and i realized a couple days before like you know there's not really an outlet that's convenient to the tree um and so maybe i'll try some of these battery operated ones but um i got like four of them and like they each have their own battery pack and then i had to like figure out like okay like well how do i like string these around the tree and place the battery pack in a in a place where it's going to be easy to reach it's just it, it's not a very well-decorated tree. I will put pictures of it on Twitter since I asked everybody's advice, but you have to understand that the reason it's not very well-decorated is because I had about 20 to 30 minutes to decorate it
它们是另一种……好吧，不，是的，有些是电池供电的。我几天前才意识到，你知道，树附近其实没有一个很方便的插座，所以也许我可以试试这些电池供电的灯。但是，我买大约四个，每个都有自己的电池盒，然后我不得不弄清楚，好吧，我该怎么把这些灯缠绕在树上，并把电池盒放在一个容易够到的地方呢？这棵树装饰得其实不怎么好。我会把它的照片发到推特上，既然我征求了大家的意见，但你们必须明白，它装饰得不太好的原因是因为我只有大约 20 到 30 分钟的时间来装饰它，
while I also had soup that was somewhat burning on the stovetop. Well, perfect. Here's what you do. Send me one of the photos. Boom. Tomorrow, tweet it out with the episode, perfect. Here's what you do. Send me one of the photos. Boom. Tomorrow, tweet it out with the episode. Yes. It's completely festive.
与此同时，炉灶上的汤还在微微有点烧焦。太完美了。你该这么做：给我发一张照片。轰。明天，发推特配上那一集，完美。你该这么做：给我发一张照片。轰。明天，发推特配上那一集。是的。太有节日气氛了。
Fits perfectly with the festive theme of our holiday special. Although, in the past, we've talked about nothing festive before. So this is our first festive holiday special. And so speaking of my travel. Wait, how did the soup turn out? Don't leave us hanging like that, my guy. The soup was great. I just had some of the soup and some of the leftover steak perfect all right well i mean that's
跟我们节日特辑的节日主题完美契合。虽然在过去，我们从来没聊过任何有节日气氛的东西。所以这是我们的第一个节日特辑。说到我的旅行。等等，汤最后做得怎么样？别这样吊我们的胃口啊，老兄。汤太棒了。我刚喝了一些汤，还有剩下的完美牛排。
what's that what matters most is the is the potato soup is uh i was like who's joining this call holy smokes what is this this was my year in travel wow i will uh i will i'm looking at what looks like a crime one of those philadelphia you know sunny in philadelphia boards it's like we we can see that the uh the syndicate is headquartered in new york there's still a lot of activity and uh in europe and it seems like they definitely have a sort of mini syndicate over in Hawaii. So I have flown 33 flights this year, 19 domestic, 14 international. I have flown about 80,000 miles, which is around the earth, 3.2 times or a third of the way to the moon. I have been on a plane for 7.8 days this year. How does it feel to be killing the planet yeah we're gonna ignore that
好吧，我的意思是，最重要的是土豆汤是……我当时想：“谁在加入这个电话？天哪，这是什么？”这是我的年度旅行总结。哇，我将……我正在看一个看起来像犯罪现场的东西，就像费城那些……你知道的，《费城永远阳光灿烂》里的那些看板，上面写着我们可以看到这个犯罪集团总部设在纽约，在欧洲仍然有很多活动，而且看起来他们在夏威夷肯定还有一个类似小型分部的组织。所以今年我坐了 33 次航班，19 次国内航班，14 次国际航班。我飞行了大约 8 万英里，大约相当于绕地球飞行了 3.2 次，或者说完成了去月球路程的三分之一。今年我在飞机上度过了 7.8 天。扼杀地球感觉如何？好吧，我们忽略那个吧。
one do you lose any sleep at night knowing your carbon footprint is like like 100x the average probably actually a thousand i lose no sleep i love planes i have been i've had eight flights in the uk uh 27 flights in the us eight flights in the UK, 27 flights in the US, eight flights in the UK, four flights in Japan. And I guess I've been to Canada once. I've also gone through Hong Kong and the Netherlands. Let's see where there's stats out here that are interesting. My flights per month. Definitely, definitely ramped up yeah in july six a month then five months in august five a month in september only two in october
你知道自己的碳足迹是平均水平的 100 倍左右，晚上会不会睡不着觉？可能实际上有一千倍。我睡得可香了。我喜欢飞机。我在英国坐了 8 次航班，在美国坐了 27 次航班……在英国坐了 8 次，在美国坐了 27 次，在英国坐了 8 次，在日本坐了 4 次。我想我还去过一次加拿大。我还途经了香港和荷兰。让我们看看这里有哪些有趣的统计数据。我每月的航班数。毫无疑问，绝对是在 7 月份激增，一个月 6 次；然后在 8 月份是 5 次；9 月份也是 5 次；10 月份只有 2 次。
which is shocking actually i'm not sure that's right i'm gonna miss some um seven in november and uh four in december yeah so wait how many flights in total this year 33 i'm trying to just roughly ballpark i definitely did not hit double digits i mean i fly nowhere nowhere near as much as you do oh and i i've also flown around the world uh twice like i've had two trips where i've gone um uh entirely around the world the first one was um uh new york to london london to um uh to tokyo toky then the second one was New York to Dallas, Dallas to Honolulu, Honolulu to Kona, Kona to Honolulu, Honolulu to Tokyo, Tokyo to Osaka to Hong Kong to Amsterdam
这其实挺让人震惊的，我不确定这准不准确，我可能漏掉了一些。11 月份是 7 次，呃，12 月份是 4 次。所以，等等，今年总共坐了多少次航班？33 次。我只是大致估算一下，我绝对没有达到两位数。我的飞行次数比你少得多，少得多。哦，而且我还环游了世界两次——我有两次行程是完全环游世界的。第一次是……纽约到伦敦，伦敦到……呃，到东京，东京到……然后第二次是纽约到达拉斯，达拉斯到檀香山，檀香山到科纳，科纳到檀香山，檀香山到东京，东京到大阪到香港到阿姆斯特丹
Amsterdam to Veldhoven to Dusseldorf to London and London to New York I told you I like planes yeah no kidding
阿姆斯特丹到费尔德霍芬，杜塞尔多夫到伦敦，伦敦到纽约。我告诉过你我喜欢飞机。好吧，确实如此。
yeah is your goal is your 2023 goal to beat this yeah and and i i've uh uh i've had very good luck this year on uh on upgrades and on traveling and points and that has been that has been excellent yeah maybe in uh maybe in my retirement i'll uh I'll be able to, you know, hit Bryce level, uh, mileage. Yeah. I think I may, I may beat this, uh, next year. We just, um, we just booked our, we're going on a family vacation. My, my whole family's going to Tuscany, uh, next September and we just booked our flights
你的 2023 年目标是打破这个记录吗？是的，而且我……今年在升舱、旅行和积分方面运气非常好，这真的是……太棒了。也许在我退休后，我也能达到布莱斯级别的里程。是的。我想我明年可能会打破这个记录。我们刚刚，我们预订了……我们要去进行一次家庭度假。我的全家人明年九月要去托斯卡纳，我们刚刚预订了机票，
and, um, the girlfriend and I are going to spend some time in Spain before that. Is that like to juxtapose with the wedding in Italy? With the what in Italy? I thought you said you were going to a wedding or is it a conference?
而且我和女朋友在那之前打算在西班牙待一段时间。这难道是为了跟意大利的婚礼形成对比吗？意大利的什么？我以为你说你要去参加婚礼，还是说是个会议？
Isn't there something in Italy you were doing next year? Yes, there is a that's in May, the GHC1 meeting is in Italy you were doing next year? Yes, there is. That's in May. The GHC1 meeting is in Italy. This is an unrelated Italy trip. I'm just going to be in Italy twice. I happen to be in Japan twice this year. I'm going to happen to be in Italy twice next year.
明年你在意大利是不是有什么安排？是的，有一个，那是在五月份，GHC1 会议在意大利举行。明年你在意大利是不是有什么安排？是的，有一个，那是在五月份。GHC1 会议在意大利。这是一次毫不相干的意大利之旅。我只是要去意大利两次。我今年恰好去了日本两次。我明年也会恰好去意大利两次。
But we are flying. We just booked our tickets on points to fly to get there to Milan on Emirates, which is... Oh, yeah. I've seen the videos. Yeah. Yeah. They usually have a bar at the back of the plane. They do have a bar at the back of the plane. And so we're flying there in business class.
但我们正在坐飞机。我们刚刚用积分预订了飞往米兰的阿联酋航空机票，那是……哦，对，我看过视频。对，对。他们通常在机舱尾部有一个酒吧。他们确实在机舱尾部有一个酒吧。所以我们坐的是头等舱飞过去的。
And then Ramona is flying back in business class. And I'm flying back in first class. Hopefully, we're going to upgrade her because I haven't quite told her yet. But if there's only one first class seat, as much as I love her dearly, as much as I typically would be the gentleman. I do all of our laundry. I do all the cooking, all the things like that. But I'll be taking that first class seat. That's understandable.
然后雷蒙娜坐商务舱飞回来。而我坐头等舱飞回来。希望我们能给她升舱，因为我还没完全告诉她。但如果只有一个头等舱座位的话，尽管我非常爱她，尽管我通常会表现得像个绅士——我洗我们所有的衣服，我做所有的饭，所有诸如此类的事情——但我还是会占那个头等舱座位。这可以理解。
I wouldn't expect anything less from you, Bryce. I think she, like you, understands that I have this weird, like, childish joy about airplanes. And I think that, like, she totally gets that, like, that I will get 10x out of that experience that she will. That's true. What do they call that theory uh utilitarianism it's you know the greatest amount of joy for the greatest amount of people yes and that that is going to be the argument that i will use you're welcome but um but please emirates open up another unload first class seat so that so that i don't have to
布莱斯，我不会对你有其他期待。我想她和你一样，理解我对飞机有一种奇怪的、孩子般的喜悦。而且我觉得她完全明白，我从中获得的体验会是她的十倍。这倒也是。他们把那个理论叫什么来着？功利主义？就是为了最多的人创造最多的快乐，对吧？这将是我要使用的论据，不客气。但是，阿联酋航空，请再放出一个头等舱座位吧，这样我就不用
have this argument but there's a shower on board that plane i am gonna shower on the plane oh do you know casey neistat i don't know that i do he's a famous youtuber and uh he had a couple of viral videos of like flying on the most expensive you know airplane ticket in the world and it was one of the emirates flights and it had a whole you know yeah shower you get to go use for 20 minutes or 10 minutes or something and blah blah anyways he filmed himself taking a like not you know he didn't get to see him fully taking a shower but he took the camera in there and he's like look at this i'm taking a shower on a plane and i was like you know i do i do have a a travel related you and i have talked
进行这场争论了。不过那架飞机上有淋浴间，我打算在飞机上洗个澡。你知道凯西·尼斯塔特吗？我不认识他。他是个著名的油管博主，他有一些病毒式传播的视频，比如乘坐世界上最贵的机票飞行，那是阿联酋航空的航班之一，上面有整整一个……是的，淋浴间，你可以去用 20 分钟或者 10 分钟之类的，巴拉巴拉。无论如何，他拍下了自己洗澡的过程——当然，你没看到他完全洗澡的画面，但他把摄像机带进去了，他说：“看这个，我正在飞机上洗澡。”我想，你知道的，我确实有一个与旅行相关的话题。你和我以前讨论过——虽然不是在这个播客里——我对用积分旅行的执念，
although not on the podcast before about my um my obsession with traveling on points um and uh that's that's become my my uh my new thing the way i've justified it is like i i need some some past time to do and i can get very obsessive about my past time so like I can't play video games because then I would just spend all my time playing video games I mean you could play video games you just yeah but I would just consume all my time and and so if I'm going to do something obsessive in my spare time to keep myself amused um figuring out how to maximize uh credit card spending and loyalty points and and frequent flyer miles and stuff like that. That seemed like a pretty good use of my time because the vacation we just took to Japan,
这已经成了我的新爱好。我为自己找的理由是：我需要一些消遣来做，而且我对自己的消遣可以变得非常狂热。所以比如我不能玩电子游戏，因为那样我会把所有时间都花在打游戏上……我的意思是你可以玩电子游戏，你只是……但那会吞噬我所有的精力和时间。所以如果我要在业余时间做一些狂热的事情来让自己开心，那就是研究如何最大化信用卡消费、积分以及常客里程之类的事情。这似乎是我打发时间的不错方式，因为我们刚去的日本之旅，
we did pretty much all on points. And the trip to Italy and Spain next year, we'll do all on points. Um, but, uh, one thing I've been researching recently is could I become my own travel agent? Because travel agents have access to the airline inventory systems. Um, they can issue their own tickets. They can like, they have a lot more information than your typical, you know, frequent flyer. So I've started researching like okay what would i have to do to become certified like as a travel agent so that i could just get like access to um to all of the the airline inventory systems and also travel agents get like great um uh deals because all the airlines um and all the airlines and all the hotels and all the tourist companies want
基本上全都是用积分搞定的。明年去意大利和西班牙的旅行，我们也会全用积分。不过，我最近一直在研究的一件事是：我能成为自己的旅行社吗？因为旅行社可以接触到航空公司的库存系统。他们可以自己出票。他们可以……他们掌握的信息比你普通的常客要多得多。所以我开始研究，好吧，我需要做什么才能获得旅行社的认证，这样我就可以直接获得所有航空公司库存系统的权限了。而且旅行社能拿到很好的优惠，因为所有的航空公司、酒店和旅游公司都希望
the travel agents to, you know, try out their product. So I have been researching this. I would assume, like, my first thought is that you get stuff in, like, bulk from, like, Costco style, you know? So, like, you have to do a certain amount of business. Would you be able to satisfy that? Or is that like a wrong assumption? To get certain, well, to deal with any of the, to deal with airlines and hotels, et cetera, you have to get certified by one of the major travel agency, you know, industry organizations.
旅行社去体验他们的产品。所以我一直在研究这个。我想象……我的第一直觉是，你可以像在好市多（Costco）那样批量获取东西，对吧？所以，你必须做一定量的业务。你能够满足这一点吗？还是说这是一个错误的假设？要获得某些……好吧，要与任何航空公司、酒店等打交道，你必须获得主要的旅行社行业组织之一的认证。
And the reason for that is travel agencies, a lot of them tend to be small businesses. Let's say that somebody's got you start a travel agency as your home business. How does American Airlines
原因在于，许多旅行社往往是小企业。比方说，你把旅行社作为你的家庭业务来开展。美国航空怎么
know that you're legit and how do they vet you to determine whether they're going to give you access to their systems and that you're not going to abuse it? Well, the answer is they don't. What they do vet is they vet that this, you know, this industry organization, the travel agents, you know, American Airlines agrees with them. Hey, you know american airlines agrees with them hey you know anybody that you certify will will give access to our system and then that agency uh you know comes up with a certification process usually involving some money for people that want to become travel agents and you you have to like like show that you have like a somewhat legit business and show that you have assets and that
知道你是合法的，他们如何对你进行审查，以决定是否给你提供他们系统的访问权限，以及你不会滥用它？答案是，他们没有。他们真正审查的是，这个行业组织——旅行社（美国航空同意他们的看法）……嘿，你知道，美国航空同意他们的看法，嘿，你知道，你认证的任何人都可以访问我们的系统。然后那个机构会想出一套认证流程，通常涉及一些钱，针对那些想成为旅行社的人。你必须证明你有一个相对合法的业务，证明你有资产，
you're not just like you know a rando on the internet um but uh but i have a great desire to figure out how to make this happen all right i look forward to you being my travel agent as well um yeah i do i do now have um a a number of my friends now know that if they want to travel somewhere or if they have questions about like, how do I get from point A to point B? They do now know that they can totally nerd snipe me by just asking me. And then I'll be like, you know, I'll just like spend like four hours that day,
你不仅仅是互联网上的一个路人甲。但我非常渴望弄清楚如何让这成为现实。好吧，我很期待你成为我的旅行社代理人。是的，我现在确实有一些朋友知道了，如果他们想去某个地方旅行，或者对诸如“我怎么从A点到B点”之类的问题有疑问，他们现在知道可以通过直接问我来精准狙击我。然后我就会……你知道的，我那天会花大约四个小时，
like researching and sending them back, like way more detailed information than they need. Yeah. Um, it brings me great joy. It does bring me great joy yeah all right well we've hit the 20 minute mark a few of our listeners have turned off by now i do i do have a technical topic but wait i want to get to my questions for you first um and then we'll get to so we've got
进行研究并回复他们，给出比他们需要的详细得多的信息。这带给我巨大的快乐。这确实带给我巨大的快乐。好吧，我们已经到了 20 分钟大关，有些听众现在可能已经关掉不听了。我确实有一个技术话题，等等，我想先把我的问题抛给你，然后我们再讨论……我们有一长串事情要谈。我认为第一件也是最重要、最迫切需要讨论的事情是，你知道那是什么吗？我其实没在私信里跟你说这个。所以这是一个你不知道的话题，但我们必须讨论。我的意思是，这非常具有时效性。每个人都在谈论它。而且显然对我们俩都很重要。我不知道。
a list of things to get to i think the first and most important pressing thing we need to discuss is do you know what it is? I actually didn't DM you this one. So this is a topic you don't know about, but we have to discuss. I mean, it's very topical. Everyone's talking about it. And it's relevant for both of us, obviously. I don't know.
推特。哦，推特？不，我不想聊推特。好吧，那我们就来聊聊推特吧。如果你不想播出去，我可以把这段剪掉，但我们必须聊聊推特。听着，人们可能想知道为什么我没有发任何关于
Twitter. Oh, Twitter? No, I don't want to talk about Twitter. Alright, well, we're talking about Twitter. I can cut this out if you don't want it to air, but we need to talk about Twitter. Look, people may have wondered why haven't I tweeted anything about
推特上正在发生的疯狂事情的推文。在过去的几周里，我曾几次考虑过发一条关于这件事的推文，因为我没有去加入长毛象（Mastodon）。这就是我们要谈论的。我没有说我要离开推特，也没有发推文说埃隆是多么邪恶和残酷。我的意思是，我确实觉得他是。但这背后有一个简单的原因：
the craziness that's going on at Twitter. And I have thought about it, about tweeting something a few times in the past few weeks, because I haven't gone and joined Mastodon. This is what we're going to talk about. And I haven't said that I'm leaving Twitter or tweeted about how evil and wicked Elon is. And I mean, I do think he is. But there's a simple reason for that
你知道的，我在这行已经干了 10 年了，不，快接近 12 年了。我见过不少狗屁倒灶的事，我也见过不可持续的局面是什么样子的。我学到的一件事，或者说在整个职业生涯中学到的一件事，就是不可持续的、混乱的环境往往会自行崩溃。所以我一直什么都没说，因为情况太混乱、太荒谬了，我坚信这种情况不会持续下去。我说的“不会持续”并不是指推特会被消灭。我相信推特比埃隆更有韧性。我相信推特会挺过去，最终会没事的。我只是觉得没有理由去迎合或喂养这个自大狂的自我，
um you know I've been in this industry for 10 years now no closer to 12 years and um I've seen a decent amount of shit and I have seen how I have seen what an unsustainable situation looks like. And the one thing that I've learned, or one thing I've learned throughout my career is that unsustainable, chaotic environments tend to collapse in upon themselves. And so I've simply not said anything because it is so chaotic and ridiculous that I am confident that it will not last. And by not last, I don't mean that Twitter will be destroyed. I believe Twitter is more resilient than Elon. I believe that Twitter will outlast and will eventually be fine. And I just don't see any reason to engage with or feed this megalomaniac's, you know, ego um so i i'm i'm just ignoring it because i think in three to six months um uh twitter will be more or less fine and elon may still own it but he's gonna have a
所以我选择忽视它，因为我认为在三到六个月内，推特或多或少会恢复正常，埃隆可能仍然拥有它，但他在日常治理中的角色将会大幅减少。
substantially uh reduced role in its day-to-day governance. Interesting. Well, that's basically everything I needed to know from you. I mean, I'll share my thoughts too. And as to why I'm not going to other platforms. Yeah, Mastodon is obviously the big one that most folks are going to twitter is a community space and i'm not um i'm not gonna let some crazy rich guy just come and like take over a community space and kick us all out so i i don't plan on leaving yeah i mean for me personally i have not left either not said anything about
有趣。好吧，这基本上就是我需要从你这里了解的全部内容。我的意思是，我也会分享我的想法，以及为什么我不会去其他平台。是的，长毛象显然是大多数人正在转向的大平台。推特是一个社区空间，我不会让某个疯狂的有钱人随随便便就来接管一个社区空间并把我们都赶出去，所以我并不打算离开。是的，对我个人而言，我也没有离开，也没有说过要
leaving that's mainly because that's mainly twofold one is laziness i have like seven twitter accounts most of them i could drop but like i would have to replicate the podcast one my personal one and my uh meetup one anyway so like it's just going to be a lot of work. But two, I also think that this federated model, like email work because it started as federated, but trying to take a website like Twitter, like I already know a bunch of folks that aren't on Twitter because they just think it's silly.
离开，这主要是因为……主要有两个原因。一个是懒惰：我有大约七个推特账号，虽然大部分我都可以丢弃，但我无论如何都得复制播客账号、我的个人账号和我的线下聚会账号，所以这会是很重的工作量。但第二点，我也认为这种联合模型——就像电子邮件之所以行得通，是因为它从一开始就是联合的——但试图把像推特这样的网站……我已经认识了一群根本不上推特的人，因为他们觉得这很傻。
Like it's like Facebook except only status updates, which is like not an inaccurate description of what this website is. And to try and convince non-tech folks, like, oh, yeah, it's like just a federated version of Twitter. And it's like, well, which one do I join? It's like, oh, it's just like email. You know, you just, anyways, I just think it's an odd model.
就像它就像脸书（Facebook）一样，只不过只有状态更新，对这个网站的功能来说，这不算是不准确的描述。而试图说服非技术人员：“哦，是的，这就像是推特的一个联合版本。”然后他们会问：“哦，那我该加入哪一个？”“哦，这就像电子邮件一样。你知道的，总之……”无论如何，我只是觉得这是一个奇怪的模型。
Yeah. And I just. Mastodon is like a model of Twitter that makes sense solely for like – For tech people. For tech people. Yeah. And that's the thing. It's like 80%, 90% of the people I follow are all tech.
是的。而且长毛象就像是一个只有对……技术人员来说才说得通的推特模型。对技术人员来说。是的。就是这样。这就好比我关注的人中有 80%、90% 都是搞技术的。
But like there are some people like runners and people outside that world that like have hundreds of thousands of followers on Twitter. And I don't think that they're going to be – Like 50% of the people that I follow on Twitter are tech, and like 50% are planes. And I don't just mean like aviation people. I mean, it's just like I just follow a lot of planes. Yeah. And it should, Bryce alluded to the fact that Elon's evil. We both agree, but I'll just say for the record, you know, I'm sure we...
但也有一些人，比如跑步者和那个世界之外的人，他们在推特上有几十万粉丝。我不认为他们会……就像我在推特上关注的人中，50% 是搞技术的，另外 50% 是飞机迷。我指的不仅仅是航空发烧友。我的意思是，我只是关注了很多飞机。是的。而且，布莱斯暗示了埃隆很邪恶。我们俩都同意这一点，但我只想说，为了记录在案，你知道，我确信我们……
Okay, evil may be wrong. It's not so much that I think that he's evil. It's that I think that he's a very sick man. I think he needs help. Yes. I don't know what happened to him in his – I don't know what trauma happened to him, but he's clearly not a happy person. I don't think evil is that far off. I used to be, in the beginning, a huge Elon Musk fan.
好吧，“邪恶”可能用词不当。与其说我认为他邪恶，不如说我认为他是一个非常病态的人。我认为他需要帮助。是的。我不知道他经历了什么……我不知道他经历过什么创伤，但他显然不是一个快乐的人。我不觉得“邪恶”这个词离得太远。我以前，在最开始的时候，是个超级埃隆·马斯克粉丝。
No, no, no, because evil has purpose. Evil has clear goals and plans. He's just chaos. There's no agenda here he just wants he just not with twitter specifically but he does have agendas he no no no he just wants people to think he's cool that's all yeah i mean that is his ultimate goal he is a narcissist and he wants people to like him yeah um but like i mean like he keeps taking polls that are see i i i promised i't – Do you like me?
不，不，不，因为邪恶是有目的的。邪恶有明确的目标和计划。他只是一团混乱。他没有议程，他只想……并不是针对推特，但他确实有议程……不，不，不，他只是想让别人觉得他很酷，仅此而已。是的，我的意思是，那是他的终极目标。他是个自恋狂，他希望别人喜欢他。是的。但就像……他一直在搞民意测验……看吧，我答应过不……你喜欢我吗？
Yes. This is the reason that I'm not tweeting about Elon and that I'm – like this is the one time I'm going to talk about it and that's going to be it. And the reason is that like I don't want to spend all of my time thinking about and being angry at the ridiculous elon musk because you know what that that's exactly he he wants all of your attention and you're giving him your attention like i don't care about him i think the thing is is what he wants is like positive attention no he just wants attention he he loves to be hated he loves to be hated i think he loves to be hated. He loves to be hated. I think he loves to be hated as long as he has his Elon stans. But I think a large number of these people that think he's the real-life Iron Man are starting to realize. He was just on some Twitter space where someone asked him.
是的。这就是为什么我没有发关于埃隆的推文，这也是我唯一一次谈论这件事，然后就到此为止的原因。原因在于，我不想把所有的时间都用来思考荒谬的埃隆·马斯克并对他感到愤怒，因为你知道吗，这正是他想要的。他想要你所有的注意力，而你却给了他注意力。我才不在乎他呢。我觉得关键在于，他想要的是积极的关注……不，他只想要关注。他喜欢被人讨厌，他喜欢被人讨厌。我觉得他喜欢被人讨厌，只要他还有他的埃隆狂热粉丝。但我认为，许多曾经认为他是现实生活中的钢铁侠的人开始意识到这一点了。他最近在一个推特空间（Twitter Spaces）里，有人问了他一个问题。
He mentioned the stack and how it's like a crazy stack. And then someone was like, all right, explain the stack. And he was just like, what? Who are you? And then someone was like, all right, like explain the stack. And he was just like, what? Who are you? And then he's just like, no, just like explain the stack. And he's like, oh, so you're a jackass. It was the best. There was also one where somebody explained how like internet ad,
他提到了技术栈（stack），说那是个疯狂的技术栈。然后有人说：“好吧，解释一下这个技术栈。”结果他就说：“什么？你是谁？”然后有人说：“好吧，解释一下这个技术栈。”他又说：“什么？你是谁？”然后他说：“不，就解释一下技术栈。”他说：“哦，所以你是个混蛋。”那段对话太棒了。还有一次，有人向他解释了互联网广告
the internet ad market works to him, how like advertisers want to be able to micro, to target like very focused audiences. And Elon was just like, can somebody mute this guy because he doesn't know what he's talking about but um uh oh god well no so what i was gonna say was that like read his biography by ashley vance and that was like so i started off liking for those that are listening this being like you don't understand him blah blah i used to love elon like i used to
互联网广告市场是如何运作的，广告商如何希望能够微观定位非常专注的受众。埃隆当时直接说：“能不能把这家伙禁言，因为他根本不知道自己在说什么。”但是……天哪，好吧。所以，我想说的是，去读读阿什利·万斯（Ashlee Vance）写他的传记，那就是……所以对于那些正在收听、觉得“你不了解他”的人来说，我一开始也是喜欢埃隆的，我曾经
think my god oh i making making the world a better place the end of blah. I used to love Elon. I used to think, my God, making the world a better place. This may be the end of our friendship because- Used to be. Listen, let me get to the end of the story. I mean, the guy was putting electric cars everywhere, blah, blah, blah. I didn't understand that he stole that company from two guys and reinvented the story and that he's been reinventing every story, blah, blah, blah. He's going to Mars, et cetera. And then I read the book and there's this one small part in the book where his executive assistant who has been working with him, I think for a decade or two decades at that point, sees all these engineers around him getting paid a lot and asks for a raise and says, you know, the companies are doing well. I feel like I've provided a lot of value. And like,
觉得，天哪，让世界变得更美好，这可能是我们友谊的终结，因为……曾经是的。听着，让我把故事讲完。我的意思是，这家伙把电动汽车铺满各地，等等等等。我当时并不了解他其实是从两个人手里偷了这家公​​司，然后重新编造了故事，而且他一直在重塑每一个故事，等等。他要去火星，诸如此类。然后我读了那本书，书里有一个小插曲：他的行政助理——当时已经跟他工作了十年或二十年——看到周围的许多工程师赚了很多钱，于是要求加薪，说公司运转得很好，觉得自己提供了很多价值。而且，
if you read the book, basically they paint this person as like the only person that makes Elon like manageable to work with because every high level executive that ever wants to go talk to Elon would go through her first and be like, is it a good hour of the day? Like, you know, it needs to be a Monday at 2 PM and he had to have his shreddies in the morning. Otherwise he's in a bad mood and you shouldn't go talk to him. Otherwise he might just fire you on the spot for no reason. So like this person, this woman was apparently like a godsend. Elon's response, take a vacation for two weeks and I'll let you know afterwards.
如果你读过这本书，基本上他们把这个人描绘成唯一一个能让埃隆变得“好对付”的人，因为任何想跟埃隆谈话的高管都必须先通过她，问一句：“现在是谈话的好时间吗？”（你知道的，必须是周一下午 2点，而且他早上必须吃过脆谷乐，否则他心情就会不好，你不应该去找他谈话，否则他可能会无缘无故地当场把你解雇。）所以这个人，这个女人显然是上帝派来的福星。埃隆的回应是：“去度两周假，我之后再答复你。”
She took a vacation, came back and he fired her. And apparently there was a couple of high ranking executives that like left the company because they were so upset that like Elon had. Anyways, this is the kind of person that like his executive assistant works for him for decades and she asked for a raise and he – anyways, the dude is not a nice person. Yeah, I have – we have some colleagues at NVIDIA that worked at various Elon companies. One of the other principal architects that I work with. I was at SpaceX for a while. Um, and, um, and he's a super nice guy. Um, and the guy that worked at SpaceX. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. He's one of
她去度假了，回来后就被他解雇了。显然，有几位高管因为对埃隆的做法感到无比气愤而离开了公司。总之，这就是那种人……他的行政助理为他工作了几十年，而她只是要求加薪，他就……总之，这家伙绝不是个好人。是的，我有……我们在英伟达有一些同事曾在埃隆的各个公司工作过。我共事的另一位首席架构师。我曾在 SpaceX 工作过一段时间。而且，而且他是个超级大好人。那个在 SpaceX 工作过的人。对，对，对。他是我在英伟达认识的
the, the, the, the kindest and friendliest people, um, that I know at NVIDIA. Um, and it in video um and sometimes sometimes he's he's told me stories and i just i i feel so bad because he's such a nice guy and it must have been such a hostile environment and he like tells the story and he tells it in a way that um i mean i think he enjoyed his time there but um but boy does it sound brutal and then like i i know some other people who who have been who have spent some short time there and and there's a few just absolutely you know crazy like like elon sending out email like getting an email in the morning that like hey at the end of the day you need to send all the but like the thing is like these stories sound tame now compared to what we're now seeing. But Elon sending emails to all the staff, like, hey, at the end of the day, you need to send me a report of what you've done today.
最善良、最友好的人之一。在英伟达……有时他会跟我讲一些故事，我真的觉得太糟糕了，因为他那么好的人，经历的环境一定充满了敌意。他讲述那个故事的方式……我的意思是，我认为他挺享受在那里的时光的，但天哪，听起来太残酷了。然后……我还认识一些在那里待过很短时间的人，确实有一些绝对……你知道的，疯狂的事情，比如埃隆发邮件要求——早上收到一封邮件，说：“嘿，今天结束前，你得把今天做完的所有东西的报告发给我。”
And then just firing random people based on not liking their reports. Or I heard this one story once about some VPs were having a meeting with Elon, trying to explain to him that this thing that he thought was going to be ready next week was like not going to be ready for months and everybody's you know trying to explain it to him in like gentle terms and eventually one VP is like just like explicitly comes out and says like Elon it's not going to be ready
然后仅仅因为不喜欢他们的报告就随便开除人。或者我听说过这样一个故事：有几位副总裁开会试图向埃隆解释，他以为下周就能准备好的东西其实还要几个月才能准备好，每个人都在用温和的词汇向他解释，最终其中一位副总裁直言不讳地说道：“埃隆，这东西根本准备不好。”
and he's like okay well I want everybody I want all the engineers to come into the office tomorrow morning at 8am so we can sort this out. And tomorrow morning at 8 a.m. is a Saturday. And so everybody comes in at 8 a.m., of course, because they're terrified. Because the man rules the theater. And then it's like, it's 8.15, it's 8.20, it's 8.30.
他说：“好吧，我要求所有的工程师明天早上 8 点来办公室，我们来把这事理清楚。”而明天早上 8 点是星期六。所以所有人当然都在早上 8 点赶到了，因为他们吓坏了。因为这个人统治着整个剧场。然后时间到了 8 点 15分、8 点 20分、8 点 30分。
Finally, at like 9.20, Elon and some of Elon's kids come into the office of a factory. I don't remember which company this was at. And somebody's like, hey, all the engineers are here. They're waiting for you to do whatever you're going to do. And he's like, oh, yeah, I forgot about that. Send them all home. It's like this man just ruined everybody's Saturday morning.
最后，到了 9 点 20 分左右，埃隆和埃隆的一些孩子走进了工厂的办公室——我不记得这是哪家公司了。然后有人说：“嘿，所有的工程师都到了。他们在等你来做你要做的事。”而他说：“哦，对，我把这事给忘了。让他们都回家吧。”这个家伙就这样毁了所有人星期六早上的时光。
Yeah. You know, it's... There have been... So you and I work at NVIDIA, and we have a CEO who's also well-known in – Whoa, I was like, what are you about to say? You're about to compare him to – our CEO is amazing. No, no, no. That's what I'm getting at. There have been – Jensen, who's the NVID nvidia ceo um well-known figure in silicon valley
是的。你知道，这……有过……所以你和我都在NVIDIA工作，我们有一位在——哇，我当时想，你打算说什么？你正打算把他跟——我们的CEO太棒了。不，不，不。这就是我的意思。曾有过——黄仁勋，他是NVIDIA的CEO，嗯，是硅谷中一位知名的人物
and um over the years there have been some stories that have come out that have said oh you know jensen's not not nice to people which is absolutely untrue um uh you know jensen has And Jensen sets high goals. And yes, he pushes us to deliver. cared as deeply about his employees as Jensen does and who has done as much to defend and protect his employees, especially during hard times. And, you know, I think he's got some of this – he's acquired this reputation of being, you know, I don't know. I don't want to say an asshole, but I think that there's some people who believe that about him, which is just not true. And I have seen some people compare him to Elon. And I think that's completely untrue, because the main difference is, you know, Elon sets ambitious goals and pushes people to deliver and so does Jensen. But the difference is that Elon cares 0% about his employees, whereas Jensen cares deeply about his employees and not just like the engineers or the hardware architects every single employee that works
而且嗯，这些年来有一些故事流传出来，说哦，你知道，黄仁勋对人不好，这绝对是无稽之谈，嗯，你知道，黄仁勋有着。而且黄仁勋设定了很高的目标。是的，他督促我们交付成果。像黄仁勋那样深深关心员工、为捍卫和保护员工做了那么多工作的人，尤其是在困难时期，而且，你知道，我认为他有——他获得了一种名声，就是，你知道，我不知道。我不想说是个混蛋，但我认为确实有些人是这么看他的，而这根本不是真的。我看到有人把他和埃隆作比较。我认为这完全是无稽之谈，因为主要的区别在于，你知道，埃隆设定了雄心勃勃的目标并督促大家交付成果，黄仁勋也是。但区别在于埃隆对他的员工毫不关心，而黄仁勋深深地关心着他的员工，不仅是工程师或硬件架构师，还有每一个在
at NVIDIA, from all the way I don't want to say down to whatever, but just like if you work at NVIDIA, you are treated just as equally and I didn't know that upon joining NVIDIA and then when the pandemic hit and offices closed I'm not sure, I didn't know that upon joining NVIDIA. And then when the pandemic hit and offices closed, like, I'm not sure I don't, I don't know, it's public. So I'm not going to say anything. But like the steps that he took to make sure that everyoneIA employees in Ukraine and in Russia. I think NVIDIA is unique in tech companies in the degree to which we ensured that our employees in Ukraine were taken care of and had options to get out of the country.
NVIDIA工作的员工，从上到下——我不想说“底层”什么的，总之如果你在NVIDIA工作，你都会受到平等的对待。加入NVIDIA之前我并不知道这一点，然后当大流行袭来、办公室关闭时，我不太确定，加入NVIDIA之前我并不知道这一点。然后当大流行袭来、办公室关闭时，总之，我不太确定我不知道，我不知道，这是公开的。所以我不会说什么。但是，比如他为了确保每个人——乌克兰和俄罗斯的NVIDIA员工——的安全所采取的措施。我认为NVIDIA在科技公司中是独特的，我们在确保乌克兰员工得到照顾并有离开该国选择的程度上做到了这一点。
We have one employee on our team who started right before the war, who was a Russian citizen who lived in Russia, and, you know, NVIDIA got him out of the country, got him, you know, NVIDIA got him out of the country, got him, you know, temporary housing, you know, increased his compensation to make sure that he had the resources to be able to leave. And just like really like went above and beyond to take care of this guy. And like, you know, like I think at one point I, my understanding is that we were chartering planes to fly from Russia to Armenia. Um, we, we just like when, when the commercial airlines shut down, we were just like, all right, well, we'll just, we'll just hire some planes. Um, and, um, you know, it's, it's, it's stuff like that that I really
我们团队有一位员工，在战争爆发前不久刚入职，他是一名俄罗斯公民，住在俄罗斯，然后，你知道，NVIDIA把他弄出了国，给他，你知道，NVIDIA把他弄出了国，给他安排了临时住所，你知道，提高了他的薪酬，以确保他有离开的资源。真的就像是尽心尽力地照顾这个人。而且，你知道，我记得有一次，据我所知，我们包下了从俄罗斯飞往亚美尼亚的飞机。嗯，我们，我们只是在商业航班停飞时，我们就想，好吧，那我们就，我们就租几架飞机。嗯，而且，你知道，就是，就是这种事情让我真的
makes me really grateful and then you look at all these other tech companies that are doing layouts right now and I can almost assure you that won't happen at NVIDIA I think there's only been layouts once in NVIDIA's history
感到非常感激，然后你看看其他那些现在正在裁员的科技公司，我几乎可以向你保证，这在NVIDIA是不会发生的，我认为NVIDIA历史上只发生过一次裁员
and it's something that Jensen really hates doing and I think the one time that weoffs once in NVIDIA's history, and it's something that Jensen really hates doing. I think the one time that we did it, his experience with it was so negative that he never wants to do it again. And typically during top periods of financial downturns, Jensen goes out of his way to make sure that everybody gets a bonus. During the pandemic, we were all given a bit of a bonus and a bit of financial assistance just to make like life easier for everybody. Um, and you know, that, that's like what real leadership does. Um, you know, like it is true. I think that, that Jensen can be, um, uh, uh, uh, tough on like the executive VPs that report to him. But there's a difference between being tough on like your executive VPs
而且这是黄仁勋非常讨厌做的事情，我认为我们那次裁员——在NVIDIA历史上只有过一次，这是黄仁勋非常讨厌做的事情。我想我们做过的那一次，他的经历非常糟糕，以至于他再也不想这么做了。通常在财务低迷时期，黄仁勋会竭尽全力确保每个人都能拿到奖金。在大流行期间，我们所有人都得到了一点奖金和一些经济援助，只是为了让每个人的生活更轻松一些。嗯，你知道，这，这就是真正的领导力所做的事情。嗯，你知道，这确实是真的。我认为，黄仁勋对向他汇报的执行副总裁可能会，嗯，嗯，嗯，比较严厉。但是，对你的执行副总裁严厉
versus being like awful to your like line engineers. And like, that's what Elon is. He's just awful to, he punches down, you know, and that's, that's really, that's really not acceptable. And, you know, and that's really not acceptable. And, you know, I think the culture of a company really does come from its leadership. And NVIDIA, I think, has a great culture. nvidia so great um is that the the the management is really great and supportive for the most part there's there i'm sure there's exceptions to this as there are is at any company but um my experience at nvidia has generally been the higher I've gone in the management org, the, almost the better,
与对基层的普通工程师态度恶劣是有区别的。这就是埃隆。他对人态度恶劣，他喜欢向下施压，你知道，这真的，这真的让人无法接受。而且，你知道，而且这真的让人无法接受。并且，你知道，我认为一个公司的文化确实来自于它的领导层。而NVIDIA，我认为有着非常棒的文化。NVIDIA之所以这么棒，嗯，是因为管理层真的非常优秀，并且在大多数情况下都给予支持。当然，任何公司都会有例外，但，嗯，我在NVIDIA的经历通常是，我在管理层中走得越高，几乎就越好，
the better it gets. Um, uh, and, um, there's, there's a ton of inflexibility for employees. Um, you know, I, there's been multiple times at NVIDIA where I've seen somebody who wasn't unhappy in their role, who their management was very accommodating and supportive and sort of helped to move them to a better role. NVIDIA doesn't have this culture of these annual performance reviews where it's a huge, big, stressful thing and where everybody, all the employees review each other. It's just, we really do take care of people. And I think especially in tough times, that really shows, like, I can't think of a better company to be working at during the,
情况就会越好。嗯，呃，而且，员工有很大的灵活性。嗯，你知道，在NVIDIA有好几次，我看到有人对自己的角色不满意，他们的管理层非常包容和支持，并有点帮助他们调到一个更好的角色。NVIDIA没有那种年度绩效考核的文化，那不会是一个巨大、充满压力、所有员工互相评估的事情。我们真的是在照顾人。而且我认为尤其是在困难时期，这一点真的很明显，比如，在这次——大流行期间，我简直想不出还有哪家公司比NVIDIA更适合工作了。
the pen during like this period and during the pandemic than in video. One final thing I'll add to wrap up this long Twitter, Elon and somehow Jensen got wrapped into it. I retweeted a very wholesome video. Have you seen this video that floated around on Twitter of Jensen that I actually don't know where he was. I want to say he was in Santa Clara near HQ, but he was walking around somewhere. And these two Asian girls were doing karaoke in some what looked like some kind of mall. And they were live streaming it and then he walks around in the background and I'm not sure if they noticed or someone in their like twitch chat stream pointed out that Jensen was behind
最后我还要补充一点，来结束这个关于长推文、埃隆以及不知怎么被牵扯进来的黄仁勋的话题。我转推了一个非常温馨的视频。你见过这个在推特上流传的关于黄仁勋的视频吗？我其实不知道他在哪里。我想说他在总部附近的圣克拉拉，但他当时在某个地方散步。然后有两个亚裔女孩在某个看起来像某种商场的地方唱卡拉OK。她们在进行直播，然后他在背景中走过，我不确定她们是否注意到了，或者她们的Twitch聊天流中的某个人指出黄仁勋在她们
them so then then like uh they're looking at the chat and then say Jensen and then they spin around and see him and then his eyes sort of light up. And then he wanders over. Long story short, ends up like requesting a bunch of songs because they ask him like, do you want or I can't remember if he asked, can you sing something for me? Or they offer to. And I can't remember. I think it was he asked for a bunch of Lady Gaga songs. And it's the most wholesome thing. Anyways, they proceed to sing a duet of some song and he stands in the background just sort of like smiling and bobbing his head. It's the most wholesome thing. Anyways, they proceed to sing a duet of some song and he stands in the background just sort of like smiling and bobbing his head. It's the most wholesome thing I've ever seen of any CEO ever.
身后，所以然后呢，嗯，她们看着聊天记录，然后说了“黄仁勋”，接着她们转身看到了他，然后他的眼睛亮了起来。接着他溜达了过去。长话短说，结果他点了一堆歌，因为她们问他，你想不想——或者我记不清是他问，你能为我唱首歌吗？还是她们主动提出。我记不清了。我觉得是他点了一堆Lady Gaga的歌。这真是最温馨的事情了。无论如何，她们接着合唱了一首歌，他就站在背景里微笑着点头晃脑。这是我有生以来在任何CEO身上见过最温馨的事情了。
And anyways, I'll find that video that I retweeted, put it in the links. And point is, Elon sucks. We're, I think both, I mean, I got a little concerned the first time I really saw a red flag because there's been a ton of things that people are talking about the website's becoming more hostile honestly in my little tech sphere I haven't noticed much there's been a couple small bugs that I've seen nothing that's like looks like the website's going down but when they said that they were going to start blocking linking to other social platforms but I was not concerned about that because it was obvious that
无论如何，我会找到我转推的那个视频，把它放在链接里。重点是，埃隆太糟糕了。我们，我想大家都，我是说，当我第一次真正看到危险信号时我有点担心，因为人们一直在谈论网站变得越来越充满敌意，老实说在我这个小小的科技圈子里我没有注意到太多，我看到了一些小漏洞，没有一个看起来像是网站要瘫痪的样子。但是当他们说要开始屏蔽指向其他社交平台的链接时，我并不担心，因为很明显
that was going to be reversed yeah which which they did revert yeah but like that was the first time i was like it's first of all the irony of mr free speech uh but like we don't need to talk about that but then i was like if this is if this actually sticks like this is the first thing that i've seen where i'm like well maybe this is actually the beginning of the end. See, my philosophy is I just I strongly believe that none of it's going to stick. It is unfortunate that Elon is doing his learning in public like this. Like, it's unfortunate that like that this is how he's going to have to learn is by like you know just trashing the site for some period of time and it is you know we we also we also haven't talked about we haven't really talked about like the human impact of um uh of Elon being at Twitter it is um
这会被撤销，是的，他们也确实撤销了，是的。但那是我第一次觉得——首先，这位“言论自由先生”具有极大的讽刺意味，嗯，但我们不需要谈论这个。然后我就想，如果这个政策真的坚持下去，这就是我看到的头一个让我觉得，也许这真的是末日开始的迹象。你看，我的哲学是，我坚决认为这些都不会持久。很遗憾埃隆在公开场合这样摸索着学习。就像，很遗憾，这就是他不得不学习的方式——通过在一段时间内把网站搞得一团糟，而且，你知道，我们，我们也没有谈论——我们其实没有谈论过，埃隆入主推特给人类带来的影响，这真是
it is completely inexcusable it is it is criminal uh uh what he has done to the employees of twitter and just the arbitrary nature with which peoples you know have been fired or like forced to resign um like you know like i do think that that twitter will be fine i think in spite of elon and i think that it'll be fine because of all the great engineering and all the great, not just engineering, but all the great work that the people who have built Twitter have done over the years. And that's why I believe that it will be fine because it's a great platform. And I don't think that one asshole can overdo it, can undo it overnight or, um, undo it, uh, you know, overnight or even, you know, over the period of a few months. But, um, you know, what, what can't be fixed is the, the, uh, the trauma and the, uh, uh, the uncertainty, um, that's been unleashed on these people's lives um uh you know that's
完全不可原谅的，这简直是犯罪，嗯，嗯，他对推特员工所做的事情，以及人们被解雇或被迫辞职的这种随意的性质——就像，你知道，我确实认为推特会没事的，我认为尽管有埃隆，它还是会没事，我认为它会没事是因为所有伟大的工程，以及所有伟大的——不仅仅是工程，还有多年来构建推特的那些优秀员工所做的大量伟大工作。这就是为什么我相信它会没一个伟大的平台。我不认为一个混蛋能在一夜之间，或者，嗯，甚至在几个月的时间里把它毁掉。但是，嗯，你知道，什么事是无法修复的呢？那就是被释放到这些人的生活中的创伤、不确定性，嗯，你知道，那真是
that's really just completely inexcusable it's like like say whatever you want uh about like elon's you know uh management of like the technical aspects of things um i almost to some degree don't care about you know whether spacex or tesla or twitter are successful as companies because of how poorly he treats his people like ultimately companies are just collections of people and it doesn't it doesn't matter if you build great things if you you do it by um you know, being awful to people along the way. You know, I don't want to make drastic comparisons. So I'm not going to. I'm not going to.
完全不可原谅的。这就像——不管你怎么说埃隆对技术层面的管理……我几乎在某种程度上不在乎SpaceX、特斯拉或推特作为公司是否成功，因为他对待员工的方式太糟糕了。归根结底，公司只是一群人的集合，如果你在前进的过程中靠的是对别人态度恶劣，那么你建树再多也无济于事。你知道，我不想做激烈的对比。所以我不打算这么做。我不打算这么做。
But I'll just say that, you know, history has shown on multiple occasions that the ends don't justify the means it doesn't it doesn't matter um if if you've made great scientific achievements if you've done it at the cost of you know human suffering um and and i and i think that that's what that's exactly what he's done and i mean you know it's it's it's a little bit drastic to say that because obviously people you know um if you're an engineer that works at tesla or spacex and and elon's you know really going to ask you you're still like a an engineer in a in in a you know in a pretty cushy job in a first world country um you know getting paid a decent amount you know you're not you know starving in some a decent amount, you know, you're not, you know, starving in some
但我只想说，历史多次证明，目的不能证明手段是正当的。这并没有——这并不重要，嗯，如果你取得了伟大的科学成就，代价却是人类的痛苦，嗯，而且我认为——我认为这正是他所做的。我的意思是，你知道，这样说有点极端，因为显然人们，如果你是特斯拉或SpaceX的工程师，而埃隆确实要求你做这做那，你仍然是一个工程师，在第一世界国家拥有一份相当优渥的工作，拿着还不错的薪水，你并不是——在世界的某个其他地方挨饿，你依然是幸运的，但人们不应该被那样对待。
other part of the world, you're still fortunate, but people don't shouldn't be treated like that. Yeah, I am sure behind the scenes, there are a ton of labor lawyers involved with folks that were let go because literally, like, and not only were they let go in a demonstrably, like, terrible way without cause, it seemed, but they did it, like,rably like terrible way without cause it seemed but they did it like publicly like on like there's a track record of like oh you'd said something all right you're fired yeah um and uh like literally i would see those tweets and then like someone replying like all right easiest labor like lawyer case in history because like it's literally proof of like wrongful termination and without
是的，我确信在幕后，有大量的劳动法律师介入了那些被解雇的员工的事情，因为字面意义上，而且不仅他们被解雇的方式明显非常糟糕、似乎没有正当理由，而且他们是以一种公开的方式这么做的——就像有记录显示，哦，你说了什么，好吧，你被解雇了。是的，嗯，而且——字面意思上，我会看到那些推特，然后看到有人回复说：好吧，这是历史上最简单的劳动法律师官司，因为这简直是不当解雇且没有正当理由的证据
cause yeah so whether or not there's going to be some class action or something you know it's maybe not but i'm sure that there are people working with lawyers right now to rectify to the amount that it can be rectified uh the way that people were let go and treated yeah and i mean i you know this is supposed to be our holiday episode. So I guess, you know, what we can say is, you know, both you and I can be very grateful for the company that we're working in and the management that we have. And I think, you know, everybody in tech should maybe take some time to reflect upon their situation right now. You know, having now seen what has happened at Twitter and the past few months, the, you know, with the pullback in tech and a lot of companies announcing austerity measures and layoffs and things like that. I think this is now a good time for us all to reflect upon how fortunate we are.
所以，不管会不会有集体诉讼什么的，你知道，也许不一定，但我确信现在有人正与律师合作，在力所能及的范围内纠正人们被解雇和对待的方式。是的，而且我是说，你知道，这本应该是我们的节日特辑。所以我想，你知道，我们能说的是，你和我都可以对我们正在工作的公司以及我们拥有的管理层深表感激。而且我认为，你知道，科技行业的每个人也许都应该花点时间反思一下他们现在的处境。你知道，在见证了推特上发生的事情以及过去几个月科技行业的收缩，许多公司宣布紧缩措施、裁员等之后。我认为现在是我们所有人反思自己有多么幸运的好时机。
And perhaps some of us haven't felt so fortunate in in the past in the good times, the boom times, um, because maybe they weren't in a perfect situation or setup, but maybe now you come to realize that, you know what, I've actually got it pretty good. Um, you know, all things considered. Um, and, uh, and I, I hope that, uh, many of our listeners feel that way yeah way to end on a at least way to end this chapter on a positive note
也许我们中的一些人过去在好时光、繁荣时期并没有感到那么幸运，因为也许他们并不处在完美的情况或配置中，但也许现在你开始意识到，你知道吗，考虑到所有因素，其实我的处境相当不错。嗯，而且，我希望我们的许多听众也有这种感觉——是的，以积极的调子结束这一章倒也是个好办法。
alright should I should we talk about where's my list of things we've gotten through we've gotten through yeah kind of updates do you want to do the thing that I DM'd you about on Twitter about that tweet or do you want to do the topic you DM'd me about
好吧，我是不是该——我们应该谈谈吗？我的待办事项清单在哪里？我们已经看过了，我们看过了。嗯，你想做我在推特上私信你的那个关于那条推特的互动，还是想聊你私信我的那个话题？
you don't remember probably what I DM'd you about because it was a week ago it was about the tweet about language no I don't want to do that today because emotional is the compiler diagnostics No, I don't want to do that today because emotional –
你大概不记得我私信你什么了，因为那是呈一周前的事了。那是关于语言的推特。不，我今天不想聊那个，因为情绪化的编译器诊断……不，我今天不想聊那个，因为情绪化的——
Is the compiler diagnostics a happy topic? Yes. Well, it is actually interesting because, as you know, I work on's inclusive terminology guide that went out and that's been somewhat ridiculed on the internet for – I think some people have suggested that it goes too far. I actually haven't been able to get a copy of it because they made it private now. They made it so that only Stanford employees and students can view it where it was previously publicly accessible. Kind of... I should have downloaded it as soon as I saw the link. I'm sure we could find it.
编译器诊断是一个快乐的话题吗？是的。好吧，其实这很有趣，因为如你所知，我参与了——发布的包容性术语指南，这在互联网上受到了一些嘲笑——我想有人暗示它走得太远了。我其实一直没能拿到一份副本，因为他们现在把它设为私密了。他们把它改成了只有斯坦福员工和学生才能查看，而它之前是公开访问的。有点……我一看到链接就该把它下载下来的。我确信我们能找到它。
Yeah, I'm sure I could. I would like to be able to send it to the... Actually, here, let's crowdsource it. If you're a listener that goes to Stanford, could you please send Bryce? I legitimately would like to have a copy of it so that I can send it around to the Insights Inclusive Terminology Committee. Whenever we see a new one of those, we'd like to look at it to get feedback on it.
是的，我确信我能。我很想把它发给——事实上，来吧，我们众包一下吧。如果你是去斯坦福的听众，能请你发给布莱斯吗？我真的想要一份它的副本，这样我就可以把它发给洞察包容性术语委员会。每当我们看到其中新的内容时，我们都喜欢看看它以获得反馈。
I guarantee you we have a Stanford listener. for insights, but now we're developing a standard for inclusive terminology. And I think it's a bit different than any other inclusive terminology document out there because a lot of the inclusive terminology documents are a list of things. It's like, hey, don't use this term, use this term instead. And we do have a list like that in our document, but our guidelines and our standard both have a substantial front matter that talks about like the process. Like not just like, you know, you give a man a fish, he eats for a day, teach a man to fish and, you know, he'll eat for the rest of his life. And that's sort of the philosophy here, which is we could give you a list of terms to avoid right now, but this is an evolving field and those terms, you know, what's acceptable, what's problematic is going to evolve over time as culture shifts. And we also, you know, we're not going to, we're not perfect. We're not going
我向你保证，我们有斯坦福的听众。用于洞察，但现在我们正在制定包容性术语的标准。我认为它与其他任何包容性术语文件有点不同，因为许多包容性术语文件都是一列清单。就像，嘿，不要用这个词，改用这个词。我们的文档中确实也有这样一个列表，但我们的指南和标准都有大量的前言，讨论了整个过程。不仅仅是，你知道，授人以鱼不如授人以渔。这正是这里的哲学，也就是说，我们现在可以给你一份要避免使用的术语列表，但这是一个不断发展的领域，随着文化的转变，这些术语——什么可以接受，什么是有问题的——会随着时间而演变。而且我们也，你知道，我们并不完美，我们不可能把所有东西都放进那个列表里。
to be able to put everything into that list. And so it's far better for us to teach you the process by which you should evaluate whether um uh your your terminology is inclusive and i think that's really the valuable and unique thing that our that our standard um uh will do um and right now we're just developing the um we're really starting to flesh out what those processes are going to look like and really starting to think about it. You know, like one of the interesting questions is, well, how do you determine, you know, obviously, if you're going to try to determine whether your language is inclusive for, you know, whatever your content is for your programming language or for your open source project, you know,
因此，教给你们评估术语是否具有包容性的过程要好得多，我认为这正是我们的标准将要做的有价值且独特的事情。而现在我们正在制定——我们真的开始充实这些过程会是什么样子，并开始真正思考它。你知道，就像其中一个有趣的问题是，好吧，你如何决定，显然，如果你试图确定你的语言对于你的任何内容——你的编程语言或你的开源项目——是否具有包容性，
once you've identified a term that might be problematic, that might be non-inclusive, well, how do you make that judgment? And so one of the things we're trying to figure out is how do we define like the audience? We don't want to say, like, I don't want to talk about things in terms of stakeholders because that might suggest that people who don't have a stake in the project shouldn't have input, which I don't think is true. that find some term offensive, even if they're maybe not your intended audience for your particular content, their opinions are still something that's valid. And we're trying to come up with a way
一旦你确定了一个可能有问题、可能不具包容性的术语，好吧，你如何做出这种判断？所以我们要弄清楚的事情之一是如何定义受众。我们不想说——我不想用“利益相关者”这样的词来讨论事情，因为这可能暗示那些对项目没有利害关系的人不应该提出意见，而我认为事实并非如此。那些发现某些术语具有冒犯性的人，即使他们可能不是你特定内容的预期受众，他们的意见仍然是有效的。我们正试图想出一个方法
to define the process by which organizations and communities can work to reach consensus on whether or not a term should be avoided. And I think it's, you know, obviously it's a who edits one of these documents i i i certainly hear a lot of feedback that some of the things that we put in maybe have gone just up too far like i i i hear the feedback that like oh you can't like it i i understand people saying it's ridiculous to say that we shouldn't use the term user because it might be offensive to those with a um a substance um abuse um uh problems um you know some people may say oh well that goes a step too far like you're basically saying we can't use any word.
来定义组织和社区可以用来达成共识的流程，以决定是否应该避免使用某个术语。我认为这，显然这是一个编辑这些文件的人——我当然听到很多反馈说，我们放入的一些东西可能有点太过分了。比如我听到这样的反馈，哦，你不能——我理解人们说这很荒谬，认为我们不应该使用“用户”（user）这个词，因为它可能会冒犯那些有药物滥用问题的人。你知道，有些人可能会说，哦，这有点太过分了，你基本上是在说我们不能用任何词。
I've never heard that one before. I've never heard that one before, and that's one of the reasons why I'm interested in looking at the Stanford document is because I always like to learn about new terms that I've never previously heard were problematic. I guess here's my perspective um when you first tell me that user is a is a term with negative connotations um yeah my gut reaction to is like okay that's a step too far but um I've been the editor for this inclusive terminology document for two to three years. And the thing I've learned is I never want to be the one making decisions based on my subjective experience. Because that's like the entire root of the problem here is like it doesn't matter what i think um the what i've trained myself to do is to always ask the question like okay is there evidence that this is actually a problem to some to some community like it doesn't matter like what
我以前从没听过这个。我以前从没听过这个，这也是我对斯坦福文档感兴趣的原因之一，因为我总是喜欢了解以前从未听说过有问题的新词。我想这就是我的看法：当你第一次告诉我“用户”是一个带有负面含义的词时，我的第一反应是：好吧，这太过分了。但是，我担任这个包容性术语文档的编辑已经两三年了。我学到的一件事是，我永远不想成为那个根据自己的主观经验做出决定的人。因为这就像这里整个问题的根源所在——我怎么想并不重要。我训练自己做的是永远去问这个问题：好吧，有没有证据表明这 realmente（确实）对某个社区来说是个问题？这并不重要，
i think doesn't matter what what what what matters is whether this is problematic to some community like it doesn't matter like what i think doesn't matter what what what what matters is whether this is problematic to some community and so like my first gut reaction is always to do research um and and like that's that's almost always um what's led to the best outcomes um can we can we talk about the the tweet seeing as you've spent this much time now talking about... So I... Here, let me... I had it up on a different screen. Yeah, so this was on December 14th
我的想法不重要，重要的是这对某个社区来说是不是个问题。所以我的第一反应总是去做研究，而这几乎总是能带来最好的结果。既然你花了这么多时间讨论这个……我们能谈谈那条推特吗？所以我……来吧，让我……我把它打开在另一个屏幕上了。对，所以这是在12月14日，
in the midst of our hiatus in between recording. And so part of the reason is that of the content of the tweet, but also it's people that we know. So the person that sent this tweet out, I hope they don't mind that we're talking about it, is Teamer, who has given one of the keynotes at the most recent CPPCon. I think he's actually, I know he's giving a keynote at an upcoming conference, but I'm not sure it's been announced yet. So it's another C++ conference though. Anyways, he tweeted, when reading programming books or articles, I often see phrases like war stories, quote unquote, or being, quote, in the trenches, end quote, referring to situations in software development.
在我们录制间隙的休假期间。部分原因是因为推特的内容，但也因为那是我们认识的人。发这条推特的人——希望他不介意我们在谈论它——是Teamer，他在最近的CPPCon上做过主题演讲之一。我想他实际上——我知道他将在即将到来的一场会议上做主题演讲，但我不知道它是否已经公布了。不过那是另一个C++会议。无论如何，他在推特上写道：“在阅读编程书籍或文章时，我经常看到诸如‘战争故事’（‘war stories’）或者身处‘战壕中’（‘in the trenches’）之类引用的短语，来指代软件开发中的情况。”
Please, please stop using these phrases in this context. And then a couple different people, the two main notable ones that I know quite well are Barry Revzin and Kate Gregory. Barry, I won't read his whole tweet, but basically said, you know, please stop telling people what they're allowed to say. And then Kate responded, saying, you know, we're not, what did Kate, the gist of what Kate said was like, you know, it's important to choose words carefully. We're not trying to, you know, anyways, there was a back and forth. And sort of similar to what you said about user, my initial thought was like, isn't that just sort of like a figure of speech. But then my next thought is like, I never really reach for those phrases and they're not that important to me. So like if someone said, Hey, this is, uh, affects, you know, you know,
“请，请不要在這種语境下使用这些短语。”然后好几个人——其中我非常熟悉的两个主要人物是Barry Revzin和Kate Gregory。Barry——我不会读他的整条推特，但基本上是说，你知道，请不要告诉别人他们被允许说什么。然后Kate回应说，你知道，我们没有——Kate说的大意是，你知道，谨慎选择词汇是很重要的。我们并不是要——无论如何，他们来回争论了一番。类似于你对“用户”的看法，我的第一想法是，这不就是一种修辞手法吗？但我的下一个想法是，我从来不会刻意去用这些短语，它们对我来说也没那么重要。所以如果有人说，嘿，这会影响到——
I used to fight in some war, you know, I would be like, yeah, okay. It's it, it decreases any value in my life to like remove those phrases from what I'm able to reach for. But then at the same time, like I sort of, anyway, so I was just more interested, you spent a lot more time thinking about this stuff with your experiences. Like, what was your reaction when you saw this? I won't tell you my reaction, because my reaction is irrelevant. What I will tell you is, is my process, and the process that we've used in the development of our guidelines. And first of all, I'll give you another example. This actually came up in the last discussion on the Insights in Crisis Terminology Committee, which is somebody pointed out that some weather terminology, like cold front, where does front come from in that well it turns out that the etymology of
我曾经在某场战争中战斗过，你知道，我会觉得，好吧。从我能够使用的词汇中删除这些短语，并不会减少我生命中的任何价值。但与此同时，我有点——无论如何，我只是更有兴趣，你凭借你的经验花了很多时间思考这些事情。当你看到这个时，你的反应是什么？我不会告诉你我的反应，因为我的反应并不重要。我要告诉你的是我的过程，以及我们在制定指南时所使用的过程。首先，我给你举另一个例子。这实际上是在最近一次洞察与危机术语委员会的讨论中提出的，有人指出一些与天气有关的术语，比如“冷锋”（cold front），那个“锋”（front）字到底是从哪里来的？结果证明，“冷锋”这样的词源
like cold front it actually comes from uh from from war and talking about like front lines in a war um and we never we never actually think about that connotation um uh but somebody was was bringing it up and was pointing out like well is that you know is that, you know, is that problematic? But, but so my process, you know, what I would do is I would go and start to do some research and I would go to see, you know, I would, I would first want to go and find out, okay, what are the advocacy organizations for the impacted communities. And so in this case, that's going to probably be organizations that advocate for or support veterans, but also specifically veterans who are suffering from PTSD, because that's probably the people that are most likely to be impacted from this. But also, it may be, there's other groups that may be applicable, too. For example,
实际上来自于战争，谈论的是战争中的“前线”（front lines）。我们从来没有真正想过那个内涵，但有人提出来并指出，好吧，这（你知道的）是有问题的吗？但是，我的流程是，我会去开始做一些研究，我会去看看——我首先会去找出：受影响社区的倡导组织有哪些？所以在这种情况下，那可能是一些倡导或支持退伍军人的组织，而且特别是那些患有PTSD（创伤后应激障碍）的退伍军人，因为这些人可能是最有可能受此影响的群体。但除此之外，可能还有其他适用的群体。例如，
how about organizations that advocate for refugees from areas affected by war. You know, more topically, maybe organizations that advocate for Ukrainian refugees or the Syrian refugees, two of the more recent conflicts. And so I would want to go and find a list of, you know, organizations like this, make sure that they're, you know, big, notable ones that are that, um, are sort of authorities on, on these issues. And I'd want to see whether they have any, um, whether they've taken a stance on, on, on things like this. Um, you know, if, if you look at organizations, um, for the, uh, uh, the, the deaf and blind community, um they they have taken a stance on how how you should talk about um uh the deaf and blind community and there are documents on their website
那些倡导来自受战争影响地区的难民的组织又如何呢？更切合实际一点的，也许是倡导乌克兰难民或叙利亚难民的组织，这是最近的两次冲突。所以我想去找一个这样的组织列表，确保它们是大型的、知名的、在这些问题上具有某种权威的组织。我想看看它们是否对诸如此类的事情采取过立场。你知道，如果你看看聋哑人社区的组织，他们已经就如何谈论聋哑人社区表明了立场，并且在他们的网站上有相关文件。
and so so i would i would go to these you know all those organizations i listed and i would i would make a list of those organizations i would go to their websites i would maybe even go and try to contact their um their pr people and ask if there's a stance on this. And I would also go and look for articles, you know, blog posts, articles on online news venues, just like anything on the internet um uh talking about um these particular terms um and i would i would try to see like how much how much evidence is there that this is like an existing issue um that that this is something that that is a discussion that that not just one person is brought up to me because a lot of people email us on the inclusive terminology committee or email me and ask hey well you know, I was thinking about this term and maybe it's problematic.
所以我会去找我列出的所有这些组织，我会把这些组织列个清单，访问他们的网站，甚至可能尝试联系他们的公关人员，询问他们对此是否有立场。我还会寻找文章，比如博客文章、在线新闻媒体上的文章，只要是互联网上讨论这些特定术语的任何内容。我会试图看看有多少证据表明这是一个实际存在的问题，不仅仅是一个人向我提出这个问题，因为有很多人给包容性术语委员会发电子邮件，或者给我发邮件询问：嘿，我一直在考虑这个词，也许它有问题。
My first reaction is, of course, well, you know, it could be, but I really need to see evidence that the communities that would be impacted are talking about this. And if there's really an absence of discussion on the topic, then that to me is a signal that it's probably not yet become best practice to avoid that term. It's something that we should certainly watch and be aware of, but it's probably not established that we have consensus that that's something that we should avoid. But, of course, the other thing that I can do is I can, you know,
我的第一反应当然是，嗯，它可能是，但我真的需要看到证据，证明会受到影响的社区正在讨论这个。如果关于这个话题真的缺乏讨论，那么对我来说这就是一个信号，说明避免使用该术语尚未成为最佳实践。这绝对是我们应该关注和了解的事情，但可能还没有达成共识，即这是我们应该避免的事情。当然，我能做的另一件事是，我可以
try to talk to people in the impacted community. You know, maybe try to see if there's somebody in my network who is, you know, a veteran or a veteran suffering from PTSD who I could just have a chat with and ask them, like, hey, what's your take on this? And I've done that in the past for a couple of different groups and for a couple of different topics, just to sort of see, like, hey, do you have more information about this? Or, like, do you know of advocacy organizations or authors or thought leaders in your community who might, you know, have more thoughts on this? Because I don't want to be the one making decisions about these things.
尝试与受影响社区的人交谈。也许试着看看我的社交网络里是否有这样的人——比如退伍军人或患有PTSD的退伍军人，我可以和他们聊聊，问他们：嘿，你对这个有什么看法？我过去曾针对一些不同的群体和不同的主题这样做过，只是为了看看，嘿，你对这个有更多了解吗？或者，你知道你社区里的倡导组织、作家或思想领袖可能对这个有更多想法吗？因为我不想成为对这些事情做出决定的人。
I want to consult and get input and determine what what the best practice is but if i do find that there's evidence that um that this is a controversial topic or maybe not even controversial if i find that there's evidence that people are talking about this or or are are raising the concern that this may be problematic. If I find two or three blog articles or a couple different threads on various social media platforms, that to me is probably a sign, a strong enough signal that the term should be avoided. If there is some evidence that there is a controversy
我想进行咨询、获取输入并确定什么是最佳实践。但如果我确实发现有证据表明这是一个有争议的话题——或者甚至谈不上争议，如果我发现有证据表明人们正在谈论此事，或者提出了这可能有问题的担忧。如果我找到两三篇博客文章或社交媒体平台上的一些不同讨论串，对我来说，这可能就是一个标志，一个足够强烈的信号，表明应该避免使用这个术语。如果有多位不同的作者、多位不同的人提出担忧，存在一些争议的证据，
from multiple different authors, multiple different people raising a concern, that's probably sufficient for me to say, okay, this is something that people are talking about that may be controversial, and thus we should avoid it. Yeah, it's a great point. I think it's, you said, you know, you don't want to be the one that makes a decision, but you missed the, what I think is the more important point of that statement, which you said earlier, which is that based on your experience, which is, yeah, immediately when you say that, it makes me think, well, sure, I have some reaction to some phrase or figure of speech or word. And then my initial thought is like, is that a big deal? Like, doesn't seem like it, but like, says the guy who has never been, you know, even close to war.
这对我来说可能就足够了，可以让我说：好吧，这是人们正在谈论的、可能会引起争议的事情，因此我们应该避免它。是的，这是一个极好的观点。我想你说过，你不想成为做出决定的人，但你漏掉了我认为这句话中更重要的、你之前说过的一点，那就是基于你的经验——是的，当你立刻这么说时，让我想起，当然，我对某些短语、修辞手法或词汇有一些反应。我的第一想法是：这算什么大不了的？好像也没什么，但这是一个从未接近过战争的人说的话。
And it's like, I'm not, I'm not the affected demographic that is potentially going to have an issue with this. And so it's like, it's like, why would you ask me? Or why would I be involved in the decision making process? Go ask the people that would actually like, because I'm sure there's a ton of things like that, where you hear you hear communities that you are not a part of being upset about something and you're scratching your head going like, why do they care about that? But it's like, you don't have the experience that that group of people has lived to know that like, why it's an issue and your point of going out and seeking like, you advice or uh you know to learn from that community is really what people should be doing i will i will read to you from the draft of the of
我并不是那个可能会对此产生问题的受影响人口统计群体。所以这就好比，你为什么要问我？或者我为什么要参与决策过程？去问那些真正会——因为我确信有很多这样的事情，你听到你不属于的某个社区对某事感到不满，你会挠着头想：他们为什么要在乎那个？但这就好像，你没有那一群人所经历的人生阅历，所以你不知道为什么这是一个问题。而你那种出去寻求建议或向该社区学习的做法，确实是人们应该做的。我读给你们听一段我们正在开发的包容性术语标准草案中的
two key paragraphs from the uh inclusive terminology standard that we are developing um uh okay so the first paragraph is, some people experience negative connotations with a term which can offend, alienate, or exclude them. Negative connotations are subjective. A term can have different meanings to different people based on their experiences and identities. Some terms are offensive and slash or promote bias or stereotypes regarding gender, age, ability, nationality, ethnicity, socioeconomic status, sexual orientation, etc. Terms with negative connotations shall be identified and replaced with terms that do not have negative connotations or otherwise remedy. So I think that when we were drafting this standard,
两个关键段落。好的，第一段是：有些人对某个术语有负面联想，这可能会冒犯、疏远或排除他们。负面联想是主观的。根据经验和身份的不同，同一个词对不同的人来说可以有不同的含义。有些词具有攻击性，并且/或者助长了关于性别、年龄、能力、国籍、民族、社会经济地位、性取向等的偏见或刻板印象。应当识别带有负面联想的术语，并用没有负面联想的术语替换，或以其他方式予以纠正。所以我认为，在我们起草这个标准时，
one thing that was very important to me is that we talk about subjectivity. And in my presentation that I sometimes give about the standard, that's one of the key points that I try to drive home is that it's this is inclusive terminology is not an objective search for a right answer because it's it's just inherently not objective if somebody tells you that they are experiencing negative connotations of the term then it is a fact that they are
对我来说非常重要的一点是，我们要讨论主观性。在我有时做的关于这个标准的演讲中，这是我试图回家的核心观点之一，即包容性术语并不是对正确答案的客观寻找，因为它本质上就是不客观的。如果有人告诉你他们对某个术语有负面联想，那么他们正在经历这种联想就是一个事实。你不能说“哦，你不应该那样觉得”或者“哦，我认为你在撒谎”。所以，如果有人说他们被某个词冒犯了，这就是该词对某人具有攻击性的证据。
experiencing that you can't be like oh well you shouldn't feel that way or like oh oh i think you're lying um so like like if somebody says that they're offended by a term that is evidence that the term is offensive to some person like yeah this is the thing that people just don't seem to understand it's like let me invalidate the way you feel because i don't feel the same way exactly exactly and so like it's as simple as that um but it's hard for people to understand that because typically in society we search for objective fruits and we we often want to have a logical and almost scientific discussion of things and then reach some objective truth based upon facts. And that's not what this is.
是的，这就是人们似乎不理解的事情。这就好因为我没有那种感觉，所以就要否定你的感受。完全如此，完全如此。所以事情就是这么简单，但人们很难理解这一点，因为通常在社会中我们寻找客观真理，我们经常希望对事情进行逻辑和几乎科学的讨论，然后根据事实得出某种客观真理。而这不是那样的。
There is no objective truth defined. Inclusive terminology is about feelings. It's about people's feelings. And people's lived experiences. Yes, exactly. And this is really hard for people to grasp, and it's especially really hard for the tech industry to grasp because so often what we care about is the objective truth of something.
这里没有定义客观真理。包容性术语关乎感觉。它关乎人们的感觉以及人们的生活经历。是的，完全如此。这让人很难理解，特别是对于科技行业来说尤其难理解，因为我们经常关心的只是某事的客观真理。
Yeah. And I'm sure there's some people listening to what you just said and they're like, well, what's the point of even talking about this then? If it's all just subjective and there's no real way to find a right answer, can we just move on to developing the next C++26 standard? And it's, yeah, but it's important. I mean, I will say the reason that we're developing an inclusive terminology standard is because we've seen a great demand for it. We developed, at the Insight Standards Organization, we developed inclusive terminology guidelines internally for us to use in the development of our standards. And almost immediately,
是的。而且我确信，很多人听到你刚才的话时，会觉得：“那干嘛还要讨论这个呢？既然全都是主观的，又没有真正的办法找到一个正确答案，我们能不能直接进入下一个 C++26 标准的开发？”对吧，但这是很重要的。我的意思是，我要说的是，我们之所以在制定一个包容性术语标准，是因为我们看到了巨大的需求。在 Insight 标准组织内部，我们为自己制定了包容性术语指南，以便在标准开发中使用。几乎立刻，
a lot of our member organizations were like, ooh, this looks really useful to us. We're trying to figure out how to do this within our company, like not just for standards, but just like for all the things we're doing. Like, can we use this? How should we use this? And we're like, well, no, no, no, no, no, no. that's not like what this was intended for um but you know maybe we can go develop a standard for that purpose so there is i think great demand in the industry for um uh uh for best practices and processes for how to do that and the reason is that um every nobody wants to exclude people um uh if if they can help it and and i think there's a there's a recognition by most organizations um at an organizational level that that this is the right thing to do and this is the way to go um and um and you know i think that five to ten years from now this would just be a an accepted best practice across the industry yep and it costs us it costs us very little to um
许多会员组织就表示：“哦，这对我们非常有用。我们正试图弄清楚如何在公司内部做到这一点，不仅仅是针对标准，而是针对我们正在做的所有事情。我们可以用这个吗？我们该如何使用它？”我们当时说：“哦，不，不，不，不，这不是这东西的本意。”但你知道，也许我们可以为此专门开发一个标准。所以，我认为业界对于最佳实践以及如何做到这一点的流程有着巨大的需求。原因在于，没有人愿意排斥任何人，如果能避免的话；并且我认为大多数组织在组织层面上都已经认识到，这是正确的事情，也是未来的发展方向。而且，你知道，我认为从现在起五到十年后，这将会成为整个行业公认的最佳实践。是的，这几乎不需要成本，我们只需要……
uh to pick different language and you know one of the early points that was made during this process within Insights was, you know, somebody, one of my colleagues at Apple who unfortunately no longer is involved in developing the standard because he's started the process of retirement, I believe. But he said something to the effect of, you know, when we write standards or when we write technical documents, our goal is to be concise and precise and unambiguous in what we're stating. That if your goal is to be, is that sort of that search for objective truth, then you should want your writing
挑选不同的语言。你知道，在 Insights 内部这一过程的早期，有人提出了一个观点——我在苹果公司的一位同事，他很遗憾地不再参与标准的制定了，因为我记得他已经开始退休流程了。但他大意是说，当我们编写标准或技术文档时，我们的目标是做到简洁、精确且无歧义。如果你的目标是追求客观真理，那么你应该希望你的写作、
and your APIs and your, any sort of content that is going to be consumed by people or even by machines um you would want it to be unambiguous and and precise and clear and so even if you don't agree that you know this, this term is offensive, like, isn't merely the fact that there are multiple meanings to it, but there's an interpretation that you didn't intend. Like, you should want to avoid that for no, if for no other reason than to, to make it less ambiguous. Like, you should want it to be clear and simple and have just one meaning. That's a good point. So while we've been talking about all this, I figured out the title for our holiday special episode. It's going to be called Holiday Special, Trees, Travel, Twitter, and
你的 API，以及任何将供人甚至机器消费的内容，都应该是明确、精确和清晰的。因此，即使你不同意这个词具有攻击性，仅仅因为存在多种含义，或者存在一种你并非本意的解读，你也应该希望避免这种情况。即使没有其他原因，仅仅为了减少歧义，你也应该希望避免这种情况。你应该希望它简单明了，且只有一个含义。说得好。所以在我们讨论这一切的同时，我想出了我们节日特别节目的标题。它将被称为“节日特别节目：树木、旅行、推特与术语”。
Terminology. We're going to close this Christmas special episode out, holiday special. Say Merry Christmas, Happy Hanukukkah happy all the religious and non-religious holidays anything you want to say to close this episode out price I would just say happy holidays everybody and thank you all for for listening to this podcast it it consistently surprises me that people find it so interesting to listen to us chatting. Chaos with sprinkles of information. Yeah. And it really warms my heart whenever I run into somebody at a conference or an event and they say, oh, they're listening to the podcast and, and listening to the podcast makes them feel like they're, um, you know, in the room with us and they're, they're, you know,
我们将为这个圣诞特别节目、节日特别节目画上句号。说一声圣诞快乐、光明节快乐，祝所有宗教和非宗教节日快乐，任何你想在这个节目结束时说的话，Bryc。我只想说，大家节日快乐，谢谢大家收听这个播客。人们发现听我们聊天这么有趣，这总是让我感到意外。充满小八卦和信息点。是的。每当我能在会议或活动中遇到某个人，他们说他们在听播客，而且听播客让他们觉得好像就在我们房间里，就像我们的一员，了解我们生活中发生的事情时，我的心里就会涌起一阵暖意。这正是，我想这正是我们的初衷。而且，
one of our friends and like, they know what's going on in our lives. And, and that, that, that's exactly, I think what we're, what we're going for. Um, and, um, and I hope that you feel that way. Cause that's, that's what I want you to feel. It's like, this is like, um, you know, if you're, if you're a listener, then you're our friend too. And so thank you, friend, for listening to us, for tolerating us. And maybe 2023, you know, we've got the Slovenia trip on the books. And maybe also we got to start thinking about merch, stickers. We can start with stickers.
我希望你有这种感觉。因为这就是我想让你感受到的。就像，如果你是一个听众，那么你也是我们的朋友。所以谢谢你，朋友，听我们说话，包容我们。也许在 2023 年，你知道，我们的日程里有斯洛文尼亚之旅。也许我们还得开始考虑周边商品、贴纸。我们可以从贴纸开始。
There is the C++ committee meeting in um uh in varna bulgaria um so that is the general you know the region of the world to do that road trip and my girlfriend has a lot of um hertz points so we could we could rent the car we could rent the car i don't i don't i don't know whether hertz operates in slovenia um but they they do operate in uh uh the netherlands um uh although as as we learned the uh the netherlands very strict on uh their speed limits. May have acquired a few tickets there. Anyways. Stay tuned. We might have some stickers to give away at some conferences in 2023.
保加利亚瓦尔纳有一场 C++ 委员会会议，所以那正是进行那次公路旅行的世界区域，我女朋友有很多赫兹租车（Hertz）积分，所以我们可以租辆车，我们可以租辆车。我不知道赫兹在斯洛文尼亚有没有业务，但他们在荷兰有业务……尽管正如我们所了解到的，荷兰对速度限制非常严格。在那儿可能吃了几张罚单。不管怎样。请继续关注。2023 年我们在一些会议上可能会有一些贴纸送给大伙。
Some swag. Yeah. I mean, we'll see. Well, wait. Why are we giving them away? Why are we giving them away? I mean, what? We're going why are we giving them away why are we giving them away uh i mean what we're gonna charge people for them um yeah first of all i absolutely disdain cash so the only way we would be selling these stickers would be with some kind of what do they call those things that you attach to a cell phone and then you swipe the credit
一些小礼品。是的。我的意思是，走着瞧。等等。我们为什么要送给他们？我们为什么要送给他们？我的意思是，什么？我们要——为什么要送给他们，为什么要送给他们？我的意思是，什么，我们要向他们收钱吗？是的。首先，我绝对讨厌现金，所以我们出售这些贴纸的唯一方式就是用某种——他们把那种贴在手机上然后刷信用卡的东西叫什么来着？
cards on stripe yeah i i have one that i use for umlude. But maybe we could sell some – we could like create like an online store and sell some merch or sell some stickers. That is true. And then we could give the money to some worthy clients. This is true. I mean we could either – we could do one of two things. We could create the store and then just like – I know a couple of people that have done that. And then they just do it right at cost. So like there's actually no profit and it's just, it goes directly into the product.
Stripe，对。我有一个用于 Include 的。不过也许我们可以卖一些——我们可以创建一个在线商店并卖一些周边或贴纸。确实如此。然后我们可以把钱捐给一些值得支持的慈善机构。这倒也是。我的意思是，我们可以——我们可以做以下两件事之一。我们可以创建商店，然后就像——我知道有几个人就是这么做的。然后他们直接按成本价出售。所以实际上没有利润，钱直接投入到产品中。
Or we could do it at some margin and then we choose some organization to give the money to. Yeah. Maybe we could have an ADSP scholarship to allow somebody to go attend some. Well, you really think there's going to be a lot of stickers being bought, guy uh yeah yeah i guess i i think there'll be a lot i mean i think if it's for a good cause there could be i mean uh we've only got i don't know how many views or downloads we've had in total but i think it's it's you know like 300 400 000 levels so that's across 100 episodes i mean everyone would need to buy a lot of stickers in order. What do we need to be charging a pretty penny, $20 per sticker.
或者我们可以加一点利润，然后我们选择一个组织把钱捐出去。是的。也许我们可以设立一个 ADSP 奖学金，让某人能够去参加某些活动。好吧，你真的认为会有很多人买贴纸吗，Guy？是的，是的，我想我会觉得会有很多人。我的意思是，如果这是为了一个好的事业，可能会有。我的意思是，我们总共只有——我不知道我们总共有多少次观看或下载量，但我认为大约是 30 到 40 万的水平。那是跨越了 100 期节目。我的意思是，每个人都需要买很多贴纸才能做到这一点。我们需要定一个好价钱，比如每个贴纸 20 美元。
Yeah. Yeah. T-shirts. We can do t-shirts. The margins of t-shirts are like always amaze me. Like anytime I go to like buy a, like a branded t-shirt, you know, there was like 30 or 40 bucks and it's like you know they gotta be killing it stay tuned folks we will look into a merch store and merch 2023
对。对。T恤。我们可以做 T 恤。T 恤的利润总是让我大吃一惊。每次我去买一件品牌 T 恤时，你知道，都要 30 或 40 美元，你会觉得他们肯定赚大发了。请继续关注，各位，我们会在 2023 年考察网店和周边商品。
happy holidays tell us what merch you want like shirts with pictures of Bryce's dog I just figured it would be one thing and it would be the logo. No, no, no, no, no, no. There's going to be other things that they're going to want.
节日快乐，告诉我们你们想要什么周边，比如印有 Bryce 狗狗照片的衬衫。我刚才还以为只会有一种东西，那就是标志。不，不，不，不，不，不。还会有他们想要的别的东西。
There's going to be other things. You realize though, I'm doing all the work. You're not going to do this work. No, no, no, no. Because I actually run the US shop for Include. Although I forget what platform it's on. But this is one thing that i actually know how to do and can and can do oh perfect all right well then we can get as creative because i was thinking it's
还会有别的东西。不过你要明白，所有的活儿都是我在干。你不会干这活儿的。不，不，不，不。因为我实际上在运营 Include 的美国商店。虽然我忘了它是在哪个平台上运行的。但这是我确实知道怎么做而且能够做的事情哦，太完美了。好吧，那我们可以发挥创意，因为我以为它
going to be one type of thing that logo and that goes on either a mug or a t-shirt or a hoodie no if we can uh uh we can we can do something i would say actually a hoodie that has the color of our logo which is like a deep maroon with the little white letters actually would be a pretty nice because we don't have like a crazy colored logo like some podcasts anyways happy holidays
会是那种只有标志的单一类型的东西，印在马克杯、T 恤或连帽衫上。不，如果我们能……我们可以做点别的，我甚至建议做一件带有我们标志颜色的连帽衫，也就是深栗色，上面带有白色的小字母，其实挺好看的，因为我们的标志不像某些播客那样颜色花里胡哨。不管怎样，节日快乐
we're wrapping up this holiday special episode thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and we hope you have a very very happy holidays There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们即将结束这期节日特别节目，感谢收听，希望你们喜欢，并祝大家节日快乐。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。